Wanna see something scary?
I mean, worse than scary, like, disgusting?
Okay.
This will turn your stomach but you asked for it.
Prepare yourself for the worst advice in the history of the world.
"Work smart, not hard."
You've heard the expression back in the early 70s;...
...when college needed a PR campaign, somebody put this on a poster,...
...and you can see at a glance what they were suggesting.
If you're not this guy, you might wind up like this guy.
Today, skilled trades are in demand.
In fact, there are 3 million jobs out there...
...that companies in this country are having a hard time filling,...
...so we thought the skilled trades could do with a PR campaign.
So, we took the same idea and went ahead and vandalized it.
"Work smart and hard."
The rest, I believe, speaks for itself.
And that's the lesson from the dirt.
Thank you.